hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
bills birth bill burr it is time for the
bills bills because there's two of us
here
the thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning
podcast and ah i'm just checking in on
you oh that was weary
yeah i'm full well cause i cooked all
day yesterday well we're doing a special
one the day after why
is this so [ __ ] loud it's been
popping lately let me turn this down i
actually just talked to my
my producer i'm finally going to have a
a professional level
podcast here this ham radio situation
you have
it served me well i've been keeping it
real since 2007 garage band style baby
doing podcasts and get underwear doing
in your underwear there
well nia i got to say this because i
like to think that i'm woke
i just want to say be the first to tell
you happy black friday
william you know you people have been
complaining for years that all you get
february don't forget white people also
give you a friday in november
happy black friday not what it means
wait why do they call it black friday
it's an accounting term
it is yeah back in the day when you had
election
before uh spreadsheets
[Music]
um when they uh
[Laughter]
it's holiday weekend all right let's not
make it pornographic
um they would they would have in
in the accountant legislation whatever
was an asset was in black
something positive in black nia huh and
then if it was bad
read native american see they still kept
white people out of it oh like when
people say oh we're going to get this
company in the black that means they're
going to get
they're going to yeah profits profits
and if it's bad it's in the red native
american and if you need to
whitewash history you have white out
right that's what we do
[Laughter]
or just insert white people into
whatever it is what's going on i kind of
like the way i said it
kind of kept the through line i bet you
i bet you do
anyway it's great to be back it is great
to be back
it is they haven't been on the podcast
yeah and i i think
uh i gotta i gotta say something
throughout the years being in an
interracial relationship um
people think that you would argue about
i don't know what
you know whatever you know one of our
biggest arguments now lately one of our
biggest arguments
okay um i feel like i'm pitching an
episode of like the jeffersons here
for the neighbors down the hall um
is seasoning of food lenny kravitz's
mother
oh that was lenny kravitz's mother yeah
roxy i don't know her last name i can't
think of it right now and the actress
who played willowna
on good times wrote that theme song the
greatest theme song
ever oh really oh i think i knew that
maybe i don't know
maybe not are you okay
okay i think i knew that maybe i didn't
no i did maybe not we'll be right back
with conversations with yourself
after these messages um so you're
talking about our our biggest argument
lately
lately nia you salt this [ __ ]
out of stuff i do not in my culture
we actually season our food so i know
that's like unfamiliar territory for you
people but
when food is good you can actually
that's like flavors that like dance on
your tongue
you're just like salt and pepper like
that's all
that is such a crack of [ __ ] but i did
tell you this i think white people
season food the way we dance
and black and black people
black people season food the way you
guys sing the national anthem
no the way you sing the national anthem
whoa oh
[ __ ] easy with the salt extra
holy [ __ ] the [ __ ] needs
flavor watch any episode of top chef or
any of those shows are all like you
didn't season your food enough you
didn't season your food enough
because people get scared of the
seasoning so so what you watched a
little bit of the food network and all
of a sudden you just got to dump
a [ __ ] salt lick on every layer of
lettuce you put on a burger
that chicken that i made the other day
for sure i put the lemon pepper
seasoning
and i put salt on it so maybe it was a
little
oh my god i felt my heart beating in my
ears there was so much salt in that
[ __ ] thing come on
come on and those those the broccoli uh
the whatever you put in the oven there
oh my god
it needs flavor wait can we talk about
the time you made a pot roast and didn't
salt it and i was like
that's not true that's not true that's
not true that is true and you were like
the recipe doesn't call for it
that's not what i said that's not what i
said like i had to salt the meat
no you need and you were like oh no
that is this is what happened you guys
ate it and said it needed salt i said i
put in the required amount but it was
the level it's my mother's recipe
and she's midwest people from back in
the day and you know
back in the day you didn't have like all
of these [ __ ] you know
food networks and all of that so these
are old school recipes so yeah
i try to kick up the notch you know the
apple pie put more cinnamon in it i kick
it up a little
but i don't do like the pimp suit
[ __ ]
[ __ ] that you do to yours pimp suit yeah
like the
extra [ __ ] extra like
we get it you're making money
that's what i'm just saying like jesus
christ you gotta tell me i crushed the
turkey
you did a good job with the turkey oh
[ __ ] you i did a good job i
crushed it unbelievable you just
won't give it up you are so crazy if i
don't like
wildly compliment you you like spiral i
said you did it
you said i i crushed her ass you know
okay you know what you [ __ ]
cook for four hours and somebody go you
did a good job
i did cook for four hours the night
before no you didn't you had me as a
[ __ ]
assistant you're like i need you to help
me with this and you know what i did i
helped you with it i did all of this
[ __ ] until a pot cookie kicked in and
then i tapped out
but you were [ __ ] like but then the
next day i'm going to make my stuffing
and you're
you're [ __ ] brow beating me about how
to make toast no
i wasn't you're just a [ __ ] sensitive
teeth baby
oh my all i was telling you was if you
wanted to double check
the setting on the toaster to make sure
that you were like comfortable with the
level of toast
if you were okay with it being at four
minutes or three minutes or five minutes
you know
just to test it i was just it was merely
a suggestion she wanted me to take
bread from another loaf and do a test
run
to make toast i could see if we were
deep frying a turkey for the first time
and you wanted to deep fry something
else first
we're talking about toast i mean what's
gonna happen
i needed to do like a nasa test for
toast
yeah maybe but i just was saying you can
just test
sit there you are such a baby you're a
[ __ ] control freak
you get in the goddamn kitchen and you
oh my god
i just yes chef yes chef i'm running
around the [ __ ] goddamn thing
i've made plenty of good flavorful
[ __ ] meals and now you're gonna sit
here and
lie to my listeners and act me like i'm
old billy blandface over here and i
resent that
you crushed the turkey it was moist it
was flavorful
it was delicious the stuffing oh it was
great
the stuffing always kills the mashed
potatoes with the
the the [ __ ] salt and pepper the
butter and the fresh rosemary
that was delicious as
i well that's all i made okay i made the
mac and cheese and i
you didn't make them we made the mac and
cheese we made the mac and cheese
i don't know i think i should have taken
it the thing is it says
30 to 40 minutes and i checked it at 30
and it wasn't really like golden on top
the way you like
and so i put it in for another five
minutes and i think that was i think
that was a mistake
also it didn't have enough salt
um i liked it
i thought it had plenty of flavor i
really enjoyed it
and i didn't think it needed any more
salt how much [ __ ] salt can you have
in our meal
i don't know what i'm gonna get you for
a stocking stuffer i'm gonna get you one
of those what's that one of the little
chicks spilling the salt as she walks
down the street in the rain i'm gonna
get you a little [ __ ] salt shaker
uh yeah whatever that morton morton salt
morton salt girl yeah exactly and by the
way
salt is for people who don't know how to
cook that is not true
it is 100 percent true it's like me
saying the f bomb in my jokes i don't
write a good joke
so the steroids of comedy is a couple of
f-bombs your p-e-d the joke
people will do anything and make any
kind of excuse
what do you mean by you people you know
exactly what i mean
to have like oh it's too much oh it
doesn't if you don't know how to cook
like
are you crazy salt and seasoning
enhances flavor
i didn't start this i didn't start this
you're the one who told me that white
people don't know how to season food i
never said black people jordan ramsay
was here and he heard you say that he
would slap you across your face
say what and say you need salt you need
salt
he lives in england those [ __ ] people
did everything's gray over there they
don't know how to [ __ ] cook
i was in liverpool i almost [ __ ] died
of scurvy
[Music]
there's [ __ ] no nutrition in that
country
if they haven't oppressed the the indian
people that there wouldn't be any good
food in that [ __ ] country
that isn't that indian food in england
is amazing
why and why is that because gordon
ramsay's cooking it because of the
oppressed indians cooking it it's
because yeah it's because of the indian
people
i love gordon ramsay i love an angry man
in the kitchen
yeah i know that i love the road maps of
anger on his face
from yelling at assistance i love that i
love a white man from england who's
never seen lotion in his life
um no but thanksgiving was really nice
it came together beautifully it was a
nice time small
just us it was great yeah we had we had
a good time you wouldn't notice by this
podcast no i had a great time but like
no you're right i i could definitely you
know
kick up the flavor and some of my old
school mom recipes oh my god so
sacrilegious but okay
the stuff that i grew up on i will try
i will try and black it up
wait but like but some of the stuff i
will put hot sauce on the
scalloped potatoes but you know what
your mom's uh
pop overs pop overs pop overs
during the holidays oh my god i love
those
and her peanut butter cookies during
christmas time oh do you think she'll
send some
she she's an amazing cook okay
yeah i know she doesn't back up a salt
truck
and dump it on the mac and cheese in the
pot roast
no but she has some she has some really
lovely recipes for sure
no doubt thank you i know how hard that
was for you
unbelievable unbelievable but
you know you know what i was amazed with
was when you said that you just got the
uh the turkey breast asses
yeah because uh there wasn't going to be
anybody over because we're trying to be
responsible
and uh you know oh claymation faces
gonna be taken over as
president oh forgetful frankie he's
getting in there
but the thing is what i failed to
realize though about the turkey breasts
is that it's just it's just the white
meat which is like the blandest
part it's the driest part so you really
have to work overtime
why are you making that face i don't
know it was just back to the
you know everybody knows the dark meat
is the juicier more delicious meat
okay that has nothing to do with rice
it's just facts it has to do with where
you cook the bird
the juice runs down to the bottom that's
what it is the dark meat
is the juicy meat it is and this is
it absolutely is you don't need to tell
me okay delicious meat all right take it
easy
no yeah which is why the degree of
difficulty on that thing
you know and i actually was smoking a
celebratory cigar
while i was letting it cook and um
it actually went up two degrees more so
it was a little just a little bit dry
i thought but i didn't hear you complain
so i knew i actually did a good job
no it was really good yeah your sister
enjoyed it everybody seemed to like it
and uh but i was amazed at how gigantic
like i don't know what a turkey is
bench-pressing these days but those were
some serious [ __ ] pecs that was uh an
organic turkey breast so i mean
i supposedly it wouldn't have any
steroids or anything in it but who knows
one of my favorite videos of animals
killing other animals
or trying to kill other animals because
they don't always do it now
they don't always make the kill um was
this [ __ ]
this hawk was trying to kill this turkey
i don't know what it is about a turkey i
wanted him to get it you know probably
because i've eaten so many turkeys it's
just like why should i be eating all the
turkey
why doesn't this bird get some and i
know and i'm like there's no [ __ ] way
this is another bird well this look yeah
that happens
oh my god you should see some of the
[ __ ] that goes on okay
like pelicans just swooping up and just
like eating a pigeon whole
and the thing's like flapping around and
it's it's it's [ __ ]
pelican chin um oh yeah that comes back
to you marabou stork nightmares
when you go to bed at night um anywhere
can we turn that light off like it's
just it's
i'm sorry well this light represented
the salt you put in the food
too much it's too much um
so anyway so the hawk also it fascinates
because it's so it's not that big like
the
turkey is way bigger there's no way it's
eating all of that so i know
there's some other [ __ ] little
scavenger keeping an eye on that hawk
waiting for it to make a kill and when
it's done eating then they come in and
they finish the thing off i i
that's interesting to me animals are the
exact opposite of human beings
in that they they use up everything
which i think is
amazing um and they don't they they're
not into plastics either i don't know if
you knew that
so anyway this is how it works turkeys
can't fly has that radio station learned
you must have heard that one from way
back in the day
they had that promotion for people never
heard it this radio station in america
had a promotion
that they were going to drop live
turkeys from a helicopter down to people
they were going to fly down in
celebration of thanksgiving and
you know as much as they knew about
radio they didn't know that turkeys
couldn't fly
and they just dropped them to their
deaths oh my god
they did it was an episode on wkf
[ __ ] crimes of humanity
yeah we're the worst wkrp in cincinnati
one of my favorite
sitcoms growing up yeah baby
if you ever wondered
wondered whatever became of me
i'm living on the air in cincinnati
cincinnati wkrp
been packing and unpacking something
town of town up and down the dial
maybe you and me were never meant to be
but baby think of me once in a while
i'm a w-k-u-p
it's it's a natty
and there's another trivia thing about
that the end song
yeah well you can't understand a word
the guy is saying where he's like
that he was just [ __ ] around in the
studio just sort of riffing
as they were putting the song together
and they thought it sounded cool and
they just kept it
there you go there you go now can we get
back to the show when was that
howard hessmann lonnie anderson the
chick who played bayley
gordon jump frank bonner i've heard of
lonnie anderson
what does that make everybody else
irrelevant in my iscs
no no of course not but was that a 70s
show or an 80s show
both late 70s into the earliest les
nessman
herb tarlick andy travis venus flytrap
uh stand-up comedian um just went blank
on his name
uh howard hessman playing uh
venus flytrap venus flytrap was his dj
name and then it was dr
john dr johnny fever wow
and wait can we talk about black food
versus white food because i just
remember
uh our dear friend josh adam myers i
forget what holiday this was like
some a couple years ago maybe even last
year i don't know
some holiday it might have been
thanksgiving and i was like oh yeah i'm
making mac and cheese
and he's like wait wait wait this is
like black people mac and cheese
and i was like yes and he was like can i
have stuff
yeah this uh this is what i found about
cooking is there's a lot of [ __ ] talk
and people really lean on the work of
other people
i feel like you're you're you're that's
that's shade
no towards me no no it's not directed
towards you what i'm thinking of
was back in the day when i was in new
york and i was doing the uptown rooms
and there was a lot of bits talking
about how white people didn't know how
to cook
and i went to this [ __ ] cookout and
it was the driest goddamn
and they were talking all of this [ __ ]
it was dry ass [ __ ] chicken
and it was just but i also have a theory
but like once you go past
a certain amount of people just make a
trail lasagna because you're not gonna
do it's just
nothing's timed out well everything is
like different temperatures
it's like no matter how how big an
acting gig you get when you go on the
movie set the food sucks
right it just does it's you you're
cooking for a [ __ ] army yeah you know
what i mean they throw half a [ __ ]
cow on something
they cut it up with a chainsaw and they
throw it on your plate it's basically
what's happening i feel like barbecue
too is a real like
skill based uh
i don't even know what activity would
you say everything's an
art form i would say it's an art form
yes no i just feel like
yeah you really got to be good at it you
just can't just throw anybody
behind the grill drinking a beer and
like pouring sauce on it like you just
you got to really be able to get that's
why i'm scared to grow
to barbecue as much as i love barbecue
like it's so
i feel like you have to be so precise
with your timing and the amount of smoke
and
you know do you feel paralyzed like you
can't start down that road and you need
maybe a little nudge
why because if you want to be as good as
a
uh a blue ribbon winning one of those
smoker guys no i don't need to be i can
just go to the places i know have
amazing barbecue i don't need to
possess that skill myself you know oh it
sounded like you wanted to and you just
fear we're stopping you no no i just
uh does it go back to your childhood
what is this no i don't feel the need to
to get that down pat i mean even though
it would be nice to know
uh put a little rub on some ribs put on
the big green egg and put some sauce on
it
we did that before and they were great
when
you don't remember that almost years ago
ribs ribs
i haven't used that egg since we had
kids
oh [ __ ] yeah what's going on in there
it's
like a family of mice live in it it's
that that asian
family lives in there from uh parasites
um no i actually think when it comes to
everything
like as much as i'm making fun of um
the food in england you also have gordon
ramsay who's a [ __ ] amazing
and i am a fan of you know it's just
making fun of them there um
someone tried to tell me like they have
just amazing cuisine in england and i
was like listen
i love england i mean i've only been to
london really
but i snob i just i i don't
find the cuisine there worth
celebrating i just don't no it's it's
definitely one of those places you need
to know where to go but you have but you
have to stay in their wheelhouse
because i hung out with one of the
promoters and he took me to the place
where he got fish and chips
back in the day when they used to put it
wrap it up in like a day-old newspaper
and they finally were like right we
probably shouldn't have ink going into
your bally
um so i went to that place
and that was the [ __ ] that was amazing
so if you stick to what they do well
okay you know trying to take over the
world like pinky in the brain and uh
fish and chips cup of tea i can murder a
cup of tea
bird's pie is that i always get confused
who does
the shepherds pie and who does the uh
they don't do the shepherd's pie
they're not really shepherds are they
what i mean
weren't they the suits in the
countryside and the irish were like the
artists
who came up with the ideas and then they
came in took control of them they get
mailbox money and then the irish are
still dancing for their supper oh i
don't know that's
that's uh that's an area of history that
i
don't care about what are you talking
about i don't know
i don't know what the irish first you
live in a white country all we do is
talk about european history in the
public school system
oh that's right you went to a private
school
what is that supposed to mean that
you're a snob and i'm realer than you
are
people this has been the podcast
no i just don't uh yeah i thought the
english people did the the shepherd spy
why are you holding the mic so close
because you continue to talk we only
have one microphone here i'm telling i
forget where my other microphones are
i'm stepping up
this is black friday i'm going out to
the microphone store and i'm running
over some fat people and i'm going to
get some microphones for
60 off you don't want to go to any store
today
not today today is a bad day to do any
kind of shopping i think
most days are a bad day it's the middle
of a pandemic pandemi
you got cute feet the old pandemi have
we talked oh thank you wait have we
talked about how you
are grammy nominated bill burr
you guys he told
some of the best [ __ ] jokes of last year
um no we did very exciting
congratulations thanks
all right can i go back to the turkey
the hawk
yes all right
so this [ __ ] to this hawk sits in the
goddamn tree i lost interest in the
story as soon as you started to tell it
i know but somebody out there wants to
hear i have listeners all the way in
iran who probably don't even know what a
turkey is
they want to hear about your like hours
of endlessly watching you
like dumb videos on youtube you watch
dumb things
you always tell me i watch dumb tv and i
look over and you're just watching
people slap each other over
and you have the nerve to talk about
what i watch
oh my god i watched a video of a
crocodile almost eating a puppy and then
the guy rescued it
i swear [ __ ] god if i see that video
one more time
we get it and he's a hero i gotta be
honest with you
i didn't even watch that video i started
watching i was like oh it's just a
little alligator
it's on an alligator it's like a [ __ ]
it's like he's taking a [ __ ] uh puppy
out of like an eight-year-old's mouth
act like it was a full-size alligator he
was like i don't give a [ __ ] about my
own
well-being although he did go into the
water and i'd be worried if
i would say the mom and dad around but
you know those reptiles they don't raise
their kids do they
do they no they don't they're terrible
parents
we need to get those reptiles out of
this country
so this [ __ ] hawk what it is so the
turkey can't fly so what it does is it
waits for
it wants the turkey to be out in the
open these turkeys i don't know they
don't play drums or fly helicopters so
they have great hearing so they know
where the [ __ ] thing is
and they [ __ ] run like real low to
the ground it's hilarious
they wow run across the field and they
get underneath the tree where the
branches are so low the thing can't
swoop in
because i guess like like those birds of
prey they're not good and close
part of them stabbing you to death is
they need to be flying like 200 miles an
hour
and then just stick into you like they
threw it threw a dot at you in a box oh
my god this is why you're so concerned
about like
some type of bird like grabbing our
daughter and flying off with her because
you're watching all these like
scary videos or i'm getting informed
do you really think like some bird is
gonna come and like grab her and like
fly away with her
well i can tell you as a parent i don't
want to find out
i just think that's a little it's one of
those things that you're concerned about
that i think is
maybe not as concerning as you think
well you know what nia i think when it
comes to animals
i look at them the way you season food
[Laughter]
which is what you know there's a reason
i'm always going back to the spice alley
aisle in the uh grocery store no i my
wife is an amazing cook it's just
lately lately you just you've you've
been a little heavy on the salt
yeah i don't know what's up with that i
i gotta i don't know i feel like i've
lost
you get sad do you put extra salt in
your foods i feel like i was cooking on
a regular basis and now i'm more
now i'm just more like tired and worn
out and i just don't feel like doing it
like i don't get
pleasure in it anymore and having to
come up okay what's for dinner tonight
what's for dinner tonight it's just like
annoying to me so i'm probably just
being like careless because i'm just
tired and over it and i'm just trying to
get it done
so you're just sort of grabbing a
handful of salt and throwing it whatever
whatever i'm making i'm just like here
um
yeah no i'm just i'm just like not in
the mood to be like this
this cook anymore because i just don't
have the leisure of like
making it and drinking a glass of wine
and la da da da like i used to
so it's just i don't know maybe i'll get
back into it but i'm just not
that's not the phase i'm in right so is
it because you're tired with the kids
and you can't be a booze bag anymore
when you cook
[Laughter]
no but i am i'm tired with the kids and
by the time dinner comes around around
that
6 6 30 time i don't i don't want to do
it
i don't want to do it so she doesn't
want to do it folks
she doesn't want to do it yeah tapping
out
tapping out well it is what it
is well i got some advertising here to
read all right i promise you guys
i mean i'm going i'm taking a a little
tour here at texas so when i get back
i'm gonna have um sorry
it's all right now
it's okay you can trash you can trash
you can say whatever you want but god
forbid no no no i felt it no no no no no
no no
i'm kidding i'm kidding i'm kidding let
me read this all right
movement mvmt we all know
that people are the future we all know
that 2020 isn't playing by any of the
usual rules can we stop blaming the year
it's not the year's fault it's covered
we got to blame somebody
yeah was 1969 not [ __ ] around because
charles manson was around was it 69
did they blame the year no they blamed
charles manson
i'm gonna put this covet in [ __ ] jail
and that goes for the holiday shopping
too
between shipping delays and the mess and
stress of in-store shopping experiences
there aren't great options but our
friends over at mvmt
watches movement watches have made
gifting
easy mvmt makes clean and modern watches
blue light glasses and accessories
getting great quality and style doesn't
have to break the bank their black
friday sale nia is live right now
so you can get ahead of your holiday
shopping at their biggest sale of all
time
mvmt's everscroll blue light filtering
glasses are a personal favorite
with lenses that protect your eyes from
long hours in front of your screens
they come in tons of fashion forward
styles to choose from
gif give the gift of better sleep better
focused and better style
movement has their super sleek matte
black
packaging that sounds cool just add a
bow
and you're good to go their products are
one size fits all
and their gift guides help you find the
gift that fits their style
their shipping is fast and they offer
free returns
free returns and all the way into next
year not that you'll need it
check out movement's biggest sale of the
year with fast
free shipping with free returns by going
to
mvmt that's mike victor mike tango dot
com
slash burr you like that you like that
that pilot speak near did i mention i
have a pilot okay simply say
simply safe you know there's always a
rise in break-ins during the holidays
you're
a mean one can you describe the
perpetrator
uh he was built like a sort of a mushy
kettlebell
white or black asian he was great green
he was great very hairy
crooked teeth and a little dog percent
of uh it's it's why simply save home
security is having a huge holiday sale
forty percent off any simple simply safe
system and a free securities
camera uh recently us news and world
report called it the best
home security of 2020 2020 2020 2020.
so whether you're traveling or staying
put in the holidays check out the 40
off plus free security camera deal
before it ends this week it won
cnet editor's choice for home security
it was named best of 2020 2020 2020
by forbes and popular mechanics this
system
has an arsenal of sensors and cameras
that protect every inch of your home
you can set it up yourself in about 30
minutes it's super easy plus there's no
contract
no hidden fees and no installation costs
then simply safe security
specialist take over monitoring your
home around the clock and ready to send
emergency help
the moment there's an alarm get 40 off
simply safe plus a free security
camera today by visiting simplysafe.com
hurry this deal expires on friday that's
simply safe
s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
dot-com simply safe simply with an eye
simplysafe.com burr all right everybody
um that was the holidays i am thankful
for my
beautiful wife and my two lovely
children and for
all let me finish my thanks god damn it
and all the wonderful people that are
gonna brave coming out there in texas
in the upcoming week the stars at night
are big and bright beep in the heart of
texas
i'm on my way i get there on monday or
tuesday i don't remember which but i'll
shout out to megan the stallion
and beyonce are they from there
yes yes they are i didn't know that
um okay that's it
i would love to add something but i got
nothing um
all right that's the podcast please
enjoy the music and a little bit of mu
uh you know no a little bit of music
and then a bonus episode i got it
thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcast
a little bit of something sorry happy
holidays everybody
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
the monday morning podcast for
monday uh november 26
2012 how are you doing
um i hope you are fine okay
i hope you are fine i hope during this
holiday
season that you and yours and
any pets you have from mammals all the
way down to goldfishes
are just doing great and
thinking about prostate cancer
um all right i'm actually i'm psyched to
be back here in l.a i kind of have to
keep my voice down because the lovely
nia is still sleeping upstairs
um i am basically i'm holding two
microphones right now
because i've learned how to shut off the
external microphone on this thing and i
didn't have time to go back to guitar
and uh figure out how to just use one
mic on this
and have it come into both my [ __ ]
ears you know
i don't know how to do it so i got to go
down and talk to one of those [ __ ]
guys
sorry all right i'm not good at this
[ __ ] so i'm sitting here holding two
microphones like
kind of like john bonham you know if i
could compare myself to him when he
played the
the the track uh four sticks two sticks
in each hand
right i got two microphones he's got
four sticks going a little bottom this
week
all right i got a ton of [ __ ] to talk
about this week a lot of sports stuff
by the way um
just to get you know just for all the
people that [ __ ] hate when i talk
sports this might be one you just want
to shut off
okay you just [ __ ] walk away and be
like oh why does he talk about middle
earth
um somebody informed me by the way that
lord of the rings
uh that middle earth thing it's not in
the middle of the earth it's not like
between
our world and the center of the earth
like i thought it was they're like hey
[ __ ] it's actually another [ __ ]
play what does it mean
you know that that writer sucks so bad
he couldn't come up with another name
for a planet they did that with [ __ ]
superman's
parents didn't they didn't he didn't he
come from like the [ __ ] uh the planet
of zog
or zorg that was always big in sci-fi
like if there was a planet
or a guy's name it always had to start
it with a z
because that just sounded like so
[ __ ] alien because nobody ever named
a kid
like it was a couple of zacks you know
what else is there other than zach zelda
that's it for me zippy you know
[Music]
jesus um
anyway so let's let's get into the uh
let's get into the sports here this is
so [ __ ] weird to be holding two
microphones i feel like one of those
diva singers you ever see that back in
the day when they would have
be singing into one microphone then
they'd have another microphone
taped to the other one you know
you know you did you know you did you
know you did
what was that song and the dream was
you used to foreign live and let live
yeah you did you know sorry um that's
what i'm thinking of
axel rose with his [ __ ] white bike
shorts you can actually wear
white [ __ ] bike shorts you know
not under your pants just that's what
you could wear he could have worn that
with a hat on backwards with a
one-size-fits-all strap making that red
mark on his forehead and no
and just done a concert no one had a
[ __ ] problem with it
which i guess makes sense because
freddie mercury used to kind of walk
around like an adult diaper
did he do like shows like barefoot and
like tighty whities
and he had like that microphone like
stand that was sort of cut off
she was sort of like a majorette and
like singing a song
did that happen or did i just dream that
um
anyways let's get to the um let's get to
the sports this week
i think i i watched the most football
lot of possibly anybody in the united
states on thanksgiving
i went back to my hometown because i was
going back for my uh
my 25 year high school reunion
oh geez 25 [ __ ] years can you believe
that
i graduated high school 25 years ago and
i stayed back in the first grade so when
i graduated i was 19. so do the [ __ ]
math
i'm 44 years old
i'm [ __ ] they even spotted me a year
and i'm still i'm still at my 25-year
high school [ __ ] reunion
and um i gotta admit i was pretty
nervous going to that thing
you know what i mean i haven't seen a
lot of those the kids that i went to
school with
a lot of them literally since the day we
got our diplomas
and then that was [ __ ] it so you know
you know the deal
you want to walk in you want to see
everybody looking good you want to see
everybody happy
and everybody living a life that they
want to be living that was my biggest
fear i
didn't want to walk in there i didn't
want to be reminded of how [ __ ] old i
was
and i didn't want to see a bunch of
beating down
like dude 20 years and she walked out on
me you know that i didn't want to see
that
you know and i got to tell you uh um
my [ __ ] grade held up great
you know everybody was looking good man
everybody looked all right everybody
looked like they were happy
and uh it was a great [ __ ] time
so uh so there's one for you underrated
going to your high school reunion
there's a lot of people have like uh
like hilarious react like like
it's visceral is that the right word
like if you mention that you're going to
your reunion
you know what i mean people just you go
on your high school reunion and they
just go off on this rant dude i don't
give a
[ __ ] if i never see another [ __ ]
person i [ __ ] hated everybody i
[ __ ] went to
you know what i mean and it's just like
all right what happened
who stuffed you in a locker you know who
broke up with you
what what did you wish you did but you
never did you know what i mean
you know ferzi was like that first he
was trying to [ __ ] go on and on and
on and on and on
about dude i have no desire i don't want
to [ __ ] go like
i was getting trashed i was at the uh i
was at the stand
you know that little [ __ ] uh euro
trash comedy club that just opened up
over there on the east side
well what is it on uh third ave and 20th
street
you know with their little shishi food
and a little stage downstairs
you know i was there and one of the guys
[ __ ]
one of the owners of the club [ __ ]
hilarious i told him i was going to my
high school union i was excited because
you know i hadn't i hadn't seen these
you know i like the kids i went to
school with you know i was excited to go
and he goes you go to your high school
reunion and he starts laughing
he goes what do you need closure
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was probably the best thing that
anybody said i thought that that was
[ __ ] hilarious but uh
yeah but i just kind of found like
everybody was just saying that uh
they had no a lot of people going i have
no desire
i i don't know what happened like those
are the kids who got like bullied
you know i don't know just
[ __ ] what's his vote did verzi end up
saying virgie just
tried to say he had no desire to go to
high school
he goes go to his high school reunion he
goes i hated high school
and then i asked him i said all right
well who [ __ ] uh beat you with your
own gym towel what happened he goes no
dude that never happened never happened
i just didn't i didn't like getting up
in the morning to have to go to it
you know like seven in the morning quite
possibly the dumbest reason ever to not
go to high school units like the [ __ ]
high school union's gonna be at night
you [ __ ] you don't have to go back to
your homeroom
paul verzi and then i talked to him a
little bit more and then i
dragged it out some chick [ __ ] i
don't know what i don't know what
happened
dude you couldn't [ __ ] pay me to
[ __ ] shut up
shut the [ __ ] up though the people i
think you know something i bet verzi
when he goes back
he's gonna [ __ ] he's either gonna
rent a flashy car
or he's just gonna get himself in way
over his head
on a car he actually owns you know
um why am i talking about this [ __ ]
anyway so i went there and uh
and just had a great [ __ ] time didn't
drink because i didn't want to be the
[ __ ] drunk guy
you know and god knows i i really felt
that my tolerance was going to be
way beyond most of my classmates
considering
most of them are normal got married and
had kids and even if they wanted booze
they kind of gotta wait till uh you know
the coast is clear
whereas i can kind of still drink like
i'm still in [ __ ]
not even like i'm in college like it
like it's like it's spring break i could
[ __ ] drink like that whenever i
wanted to which
is not a good thing it's not a good
thing for old billy fatface here so
um i decided you know what i'll just
start off with the cranberry juice and a
[ __ ] lime and i'll endure somebody
doing the [ __ ] departed joke where
you got your period
um and then i switched the waters and i
had a coke and i was just like you know
what i'm i'm not gonna [ __ ] drink and
uh
i had a uh i i had a great time but the
[ __ ] was i just i was leading towards
something
oh you know what everybody did and i
thought everyone be taking out pictures
of their kids i didn't see one picture
of anybody's kid
everybody was just talking about [ __ ]
all the dumb [ __ ] we used to do
and uh and had a great time
just have really had a great time you
know a great story that
i had never heard there was a buddy of
mine he used to [ __ ] gamble
like big time used to bet on like
baseball and he had like his own
landscaping company whenever like the
baseball team
would win whatever team wanted money he
would then try and cut somebody's
backyard a front yard in the same design
as the outfield of that team
and it never looked like it it just it
looked like some sort of [ __ ] up
design but he didn't know what he was
doing and he was high probably when he
did it
so somebody told me a story about that
kid he had bet the [ __ ] houston
rockets way back in the day
and uh houston had lost like two games
in a row so he thought it was a gift
he [ __ ] buries the team and they end
up uh
they're just [ __ ] in the bed nobody's
playing or whatever and he got so mad he
picked up the phone and he called
long distance and he said
yeah in houston last name elijah won
[Laughter]
and he wasn't doing it to make the other
person laugh
he he literally thought that he was
going to get i don't know if he was high
or whatever he was trying to get this
guy's number
to [ __ ] [ __ ] him out for losing or
whatever 50 bucks or 100 bucks on the
game so it's basically
just [ __ ] like that and uh all right now
you guys getting sick of this okay
whatever i had a great [ __ ] time so
if anybody who
was at the high school reunion is
listening uh it was great seeing you and
i'm glad
everything seems to be going great in
everybody's life so
anyways let's get on with the sports
here um
here's one for you first of all oh i i
forgot to mention yeah i
i watched all this football i went to my
my high school rivalry
i went to that we were two and seven the
other team was like [ __ ]
uh what are the eight and one and uh we
actually beat him in overtime
it was an away game you know sent the
other team
[ __ ] fans home with their heads
hanging
on turkey day made me feel [ __ ] great
and then i watched uh
i watched the first game it was at the
lions texans
then i watched the next game cowboys and
then i watched the patriots uh
that game was [ __ ] unbelievable and
don't worry jeff fans i'm not gonna
you know if you've noticed i really
haven't trashed you guys this year
despite the fact
i really could have i just haven't the
only reason why i ever really [ __ ]
trashed you guys
was because rex ryan talked all that
[ __ ] you know he hasn't talked [ __ ] in
two years and i laid off you okay
so um anyways
you know that guy always make fun of the
firemen i always say it gets on his
boyfriend's shoulders like he's some hot
chick at a bon jovi concert
uh fireman ed [ __ ] retired
if you haven't heard about this he
couldn't [ __ ] take it anymore
why because the patriots beat the team
so bad no
because he has to endure another [ __ ]
jets
rebuilding no because he got sick
of the [ __ ] [ __ ] jet fans getting in
his [ __ ] grill because he's wearing a
sanchez jersey
the same [ __ ] people who were going
colin
mark sanchez sanchez sanchez
a few [ __ ] years later they jump off
the [ __ ] bandwagon now they get into
the face
of this old [ __ ] retired uh
fireman on thanksgiving getting in his
face
and he finally just decided what the
[ __ ] am i doing
the [ __ ] am i doing [ __ ] these people
and you know what i say i say good for
you firemen ed
don't take no [ __ ] off nobody
here's the article new york jets
superfan
fireman ed who for decades has fueled
home crowds with his famous jets
cheer has decided to r-e-t-i-r-e
retire um i don't name names i won't say
his last name who created
a stir thanksgiving night when he left
metlife stadium at halftime of the jets
49 to 19 loss yeah along with half the
[ __ ] crowd
and then he deleted his twitter account
he announced on sunday night that he
will no longer attend home games as
firemen ed good for you
good for you you got to go down there
and dress up like a [ __ ] clown to get
these people going
only to have these people getting your
grill in the [ __ ] bathroom screaming
at you
shame on you jets fans and i know what
you jets fans are going to say it was a
select few people no it wasn't
it was it was probably almost all of you
and you know why because you're horrific
human beings
and that's why god only let you win one
um anyways he says the stadium has
become divided because of the
quarterback controversy
he claims the fact that i chose to wear
a mock sanchez jersey this year
and that fans think i'm on the payroll
which is an outright lie
have made these confrontations more
frequent whether it's in the stands the
bathroom or the parking lot these
confrontations are happening
on a consistent basis
wow so he just said [ __ ] it and then rex
ryan
who uh i i actually hung around and
watched his uh press conference
where he just kept saying the same you
know uh we're gonna try you know we're
gonna come out next week we're gonna
play hard i mean that's uh
it's it's all we know how to do you know
we just you know that that same [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you know the same guy that one year when
they lifted the salary cap and the jets
went out and [ __ ] one bought
everybody he's like who kicked the
[ __ ] out of any [ __ ] team in his rig
it's just great watching him eat a big
slice of humble pie
and the final question of the press
conference is rex
do you think you'll still be here next
year and he just goes
yes i do yes i do
any more questions and there was nothing
and he had to walk off on that one and i
thoroughly enjoyed it
thoroughly [ __ ] enjoyed it so there
you go
but this guy says he's going to keep
going to the to the games he's just not
going to the game
you know as fireman ed the guy's wearing
the sanchez jersey according to him as
like he's being loyal so this guy really
is a fan you know some two people go
dude the guy used to be a [ __ ]
dolphins fan
you know all right that works if he
jumped on the bandwagon and became a
patriots
fan when the patriots got good or if he
jumped on the bandwagon
you know uh with the giants or the
steelers
or any other team that was good dude he
went from the dolphins to the jets
okay no and he did it in 75. that was a
major step backwards
all right according to what i've read
okay in 75
the [ __ ] dolphins they had they won
two two super bowls back-to-back super
bowls had a perfect season went to three
super bowls in a row all in the early
70s they still had bob greasy
i think larry zunker was already in the
wfl or maybe he came back with the
giants at that point
[ __ ] rain man here this is all for my
football cards that i looked at a
zillion times when i was a kid rather
than studying in high school
and um who the [ __ ] did
did they even have richard todd at that
point joe namath was gone
yeah i think they just got richard todd
that was it
so this guy this guy paid his [ __ ]
dues he went to a zillion games
he's the only guy who stole the balls to
wear a sanchez jersey
this guy was actually a fan and he got
trashed by other [ __ ] fans
i find that really [ __ ] interesting
um
and it really actually taps into this
this question i got this
this week somebody said bill do you give
a [ __ ]
he said hey bill love your work but you
give a [ __ ] about your fans
doesn't look like it and sad to see
i i don't what what the [ __ ] what does
that mean
doesn't look like it does is my website
subpar
i know the audio was bad last week but
well you know
you get sir you're gonna have to
elaborate a little bit more what
happened did you had did you
you keep sending emails and i haven't
read one yet
did you have a cold last week and asked
me to send you a [ __ ] card and i did
what
what does that mean do i give a [ __ ]
about my fans
first of all i i don't know all right
this is what i feel like i feel you have
a [ __ ] responsibility to give
somebody a goddamn show
that's what you have go out there give
somebody their [ __ ] buddies worth
all right and i like to think i do that
so what where where the [ __ ] is that
coming
what more what do i got to do for you
wear the t-shirt of your company
you know
you think that's sad you know i think
this is [ __ ] sad i think that [ __ ]
email said
what are you doing
you know what the i don't even know
where the [ __ ] that comes from
do i give a [ __ ] about it no i don't i
want to go back to standing in a a
[ __ ] function room in a hotel room in
front of 80 people who didn't even know
there was going to be comedy give me a
[ __ ] break
okay i don't i don't know what your your
level of uh
i have to give [ __ ] let me ask you let
me ask you a question sir
do you give a [ __ ] about the the
the people that you're fans of
you know because i i got to be honest
with you
i don't i thought i did but i
[ __ ] love ac dc
absolutely [ __ ] love them and i
they're a bad example because they've
never really fell off they've always
sold a bunch of albums
i loved a lot of bands in the 80s loved
them
all right but when they fell off in the
[ __ ] 90s
i didn't keep going to their shows i
didn't send them cards going hey man
hang in there i didn't
i totally [ __ ] flipped and made
fun of them i make fun of hair metal to
this day
i guess i make fun of myself too saying
i i can't believe some of the [ __ ]
shows i went to
but you know what i mean it's those
people who are still [ __ ] going to
those shows with their hairs teased up
acid washed jeans this fireman head
sitting there we're still wearing a
sanchez
sanchez jean [ __ ] jersey i guess that
that is a true
fanatic but the rest of us i think are
uh you know we're [ __ ] hot and cold
isn't the real relationship most fans
have with the musician
uh an actor uh [ __ ] whatever
um an athlete don't aren't you really
kind of just a fan
as long as they're good you know
they sold a lot of sanchez jerseys
okay and everybody loved them until he
didn't start playing well
and now everybody [ __ ] hates him
you know
i think that's that's more that's the
reality
you know so you don't sound well i don't
know i don't know where that's coming
from so i can't really judge you but uh
i i do give a [ __ ] about the people who
come to my shows
uh unless they have some sense of
entitlement
where they feel like you know
i bought a ticket to your show
and despite the fact that you then did a
show so i already got my money's worth
that
i definitely deserve more [ __ ]
you know they don't consider the bonus
round
you know taking pictures and signing
whatever the [ __ ] they want they don't
consider
that like oh hey this guy's actually
this guy technically doesn't even have
to [ __ ] be out here and he came out
here
most people appreciate that oh glad you
came out you know uh yeah you know
thank you for coming out right that
[ __ ] little tit for tat thing
those people who [ __ ] sit there and
they come up hammered and
they have like uh you know signed 500
[ __ ] things and i want to have a
20-minute conversation with you despite
the fact there's another 40 people
waiting
behind you who also have jobs and [ __ ]
to do and when i say
i'm sorry there's other people and then
you flip out and say that i'm some prima
donna [ __ ]
yeah i don't give a [ __ ] about them i
hope i answered your question sir
you you i you have me wondering what i
need to go redo my [ __ ] website maybe
update some more [ __ ] photos
you know look there's people out there
there's there's comedians out there
who are funny and are really good at
recording themselves
and have really interactive websites if
that's what you're looking for i
i hate to say you you stopped at the
wrong kiosk
because uh i'm kind of not that guy
all right okay there we go all right hey
you know what
why don't we uh why don't we drop out of
that we'll do a little bit of uh
all things comedy everybody would you
like to know what's going on on the all
things comedy network
the the the podcasting network that i
was started by myself
al madrigal and a couple other peoples
there um
that will eventually take over the
podcasting world
um here's some updates tom segura
absolutely [ __ ] hilarious
um telling you this guy is gonna be one
of the guys
all right he's doing an hour-long comedy
special december 4th at flappa's
comedy club in burbank a great
old-school comedy club in burbank
plenty of parking uh not a bad seat in
the house he wants the club packed
please um let's see he says please
extend an offer to be placed on tom's
guest list tell your audience to email
tom at tomsegora
me.com it's t-o-m capital s
e g u r a at me
dot com um and how many tickets they
want and be sure to write december 4th
in the subject line so i guess these are
free tickets
you guys want to go to a free show great
up and coming comic here
telling you going to be one of the guys
free show flappers comedy club december
4th
email tom segura at me.com how many
tickets you want with december 4th in
the subject line all right a couple
other ones um
randy from the bone zone the bone zone
a new podcast added to all things comedy
on a recent episode he had the creator
of the cartoon network
show adventure time penn ward as a guest
if you'd like to listen to that
and uh greg barron of the walking room
uh his band the reigning monarchs
uh start an indiegogo campaign to make a
record tomorrow it'll be going on for
the next 45 days if you could plug
that would be awesome if not i'll hang
myself okay that was the part he wrote
[Laughter]
anyways go to all things comedy baron's
[ __ ] hilarious uh
and check that [ __ ] out okay and that is
it all right now
back to the [ __ ] spo oh wait i got i
got to read a little [ __ ] advertising
here i got i got to grease the uh grease
the palms here
what do we got here what do we got here
oh stamps.com everybody
um hey you want to stop going to the
post office
and you would you just like to be able
to do everything you do in the post
office at home just go to stamps.com you
can avoid all the hassle man
of going to the post office during the
busy holiday season
oh yeah this is even more of a bonus
you'd only be going down there because
you know you're going to shop late and
then you got to ship all your crap back
to these people you don't even care
about okay wouldn't it be nice to not
have to stand in line to do that
everything you want to do at the post
office you can do right from your desk
or at home
sitting in your pajamas you can buy and
print official us postage using your own
computer and printer
print postage for any letter uh or
package the instant you need it then
mail
then the mailman picks it up so easy and
convenient i use stamps.com
to send all of my dvds to any of the
road gigs that i have you should do it
too right now you get a special offer
when
you use my name bur b-u-r-r uh no risk
trial plus 110 dollar bonus offer
includes a digital scale
and up to 55 dollars in free postage
they're giving you 55 bucks
during the holiday season so don't wait
go to stamps.com before you do anything
else click at the microphone on the top
of the home page and type in burr burr
that stamps dot com enter bur b u r r
okay back to the podcast so
um all right here's a
here's another [ __ ] thing i got a a
bone i have to pick hey you know
something i really came down hard on the
jets
fans i know a lot of you fans didn't
leave you guys are the real [ __ ] fans
and towards the end of that game
if you looked around if you really want
to see the real fans
yeah if you were still [ __ ] there and
not wearing a patriots jersey
i always hate people who [ __ ] leave
early when your team's taking an ass
kicking from the other team because then
the other team's fans get to like
air quote take over your your stadium
you should never let that happen
okay you should have them walking out
with their heads down nervous that
they're going to get beat down by 60 000
[ __ ] fans that's that's what i feel
um all right
okay as always okay we [ __ ] with the
east coast now how about the west coast
did you guys see uh
kobe bryant the other night i forget who
the [ __ ] they were playing they lost
another game
things aren't going well out there so
there's 10 seconds left in the game
you know there's no way the lakers can
come back to down like by eight or nine
or something like that so the other team
has the ball they get
inbounded they're at half court and
they're just standing there dribbling it
out
right and you just stand there you wait
and the horn blows
and then everybody just goes and shake
hands then you go in the locker room
well kobe
you know he'd scored 30 points that
night and evidently thought he was god's
gift to [ __ ] everything
he just walks off the court left his
teammates there
right one of the most diva [ __ ]
things
i've ever seen in my life just [ __ ]
walks off court
with the whole hey i scored 30 points i
don't know what's wrong with the rest of
you
totally setting himself apart just an
absolute
[ __ ] cancer right
so i'm watching espn going hey let's see
what they're gonna do is he they finally
gonna [ __ ] criticize this guy steven
a
smith who i love who will rip somebody a
new [ __ ]
whenever it is deserved he goes on and
he goes
and they go stephen a smith what do you
think about that how he just walked off
you see dwight howard looking at him
like are you serious
what do you think about that and stephen
a smith was just like well
kobe bryant has a very high basketball
iq
which i don't know what that [ __ ]
means he has a very high basketball iq
so what does that mean he
but he can't use a fork you know
i mean the guy has been the best guy in
the league for like what 10 12 [ __ ]
years
but whatever he has a very high
basketball iq
and this is just evident evidence of the
level of frustration the man is feeling
about the current state of the situation
i mean pogba saw he could not hit a shot
and he starts ripping all the other
[ __ ] lakers
it's just that's the type of [ __ ] i
can't [ __ ] stand just sitting there
kissing the ass of a [ __ ] star
kobe bryant is a [ __ ] cancer the guys
he ran shaq out of town you know they
won three [ __ ] titles and he still
wasn't happy
he goes to ryko remember that shaq
gone goes to miami won a title there's
another one the lakers could have got
that year
you know not enough don't want to win
i'd rather have it all be me
it's all about me right
he should have been benched benched for
the first quarter of the next game
and this is the same guy that they talk
about in the same breath as michael
jordan
the magic johnsons the larry birds let
me tell you something those guys never
would have done that [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
ridiculous
[ __ ] ridiculous that guy
can you imagine that now you got to go
walk in the locker room after kobe just
left
left you out there like yeah you guys
all suck
go [ __ ] yourselves and then you got to
walk into the locker room and you
what you can't say anything to him
you know what they should they should
have [ __ ] gone in there and all of
them just hung him by his [ __ ] shorts
give him a big wedgie
how high would that hook have to be i
mean what is he [ __ ] six eight
i mean what give me a [ __ ] you just
walk out
and then stephen a smith doesn't say
anything about it
he just starts talking about how smart
he is at the game of basketball
and how he's really frustrated like the
other lakers aren't frustrated
let me ask you this laker fans how many
[ __ ] there's a great thing about
laker fence too these [ __ ]
morons the very next game will be
chanting
mvp at a guy who's run
coaches out of town ran shaq out of town
[ __ ] the team out of another [ __ ]
championship
most likely he had shaq in his prime
that's another thing too this [ __ ]
guy
has had the lakers organization he
hasn't by the short hairs
hasn't by the [ __ ] balls he does
whatever he wants to do it's
embarrassing
d'antoni should have sat him he should
have walked right in the locker room
just like kobe what the [ __ ] was that
you know this is a team you're not
playing the first quarter tomorrow night
hey i don't want to hear it shut your
face for once in your [ __ ] life do i
have to say it in italian too
and you know what he'd be a better
player because of it
they should have a team meeting and
address his cuntiness
you know you know he get all emotional
you know what he does when he puckers up
his lips
you know like he did when uh when they
got beat by the the pistons or he got
beaten up in the the
conference finals or that skank out in
[ __ ] uh
denver said the [ __ ] he said about him
and he did that thing with his lips
that's what he would do
yeah kobe you're kind of a [ __ ] and he'd
start making that face
look the guy's a beast he wants to win
i totally respect that you know you
don't do that to your [ __ ] teammates
and
stephen a smith you know what shame on
you you have a very high
broadcaster iq you you know what the
[ __ ] he did
and you know why you didn't hold his
feet to the fire then you go i [ __ ]
pogbasal
you go after the guy who looks like a
giant kenny loggins
come on
i don't know i don't like that i don't
like that star ass kicks it because you
know what happens is if you [ __ ] on him
then you can't get the interviews
anymore you know what i mean
or maybe he played some sort of pickup
game at your son's eight-year-old
birthday party and you don't want to
jeopardize that for the nine-year-old
birthday just something going on there
where i was just i couldn't [ __ ]
believe it
the [ __ ] guy walks off court the
court with 10 seconds left
[ __ ] all you guys this wasn't my fault
it's your fault
what else could it mean you guys take
the [ __ ] loss you take this
embarrassing loss i'm above this
stephen a smith he has a very high
basketball oh my god
disgusting um that was it was borderline
offensive
i never get offended um all right
here we go hello bill my name is
stephanie
malo malazzi okay
why did i just read your [ __ ] name
well you know what you said it
uh my my fiance my fiance and i are fans
we saw him in new york in new haven i'm
looking
to find more information regarding
booking bill for my wedding
uh in 2014.
all right now this email was sent to me
because they thought that i would think
that this gig was funny and was beneath
me but
2014 is a long ways off so
[Laughter]
who knows what could happen
you know ma'am you know something
there's no way i would ever
uh work a wedding because uh just out of
respect for your grandmother
and everybody else who's gonna be there
and uh you know what i mean
but i'm i'm definitely not above it a
long time ago i got
i got a trash in from uh the late great
patrice o'neill kevin hart rich voss
jim norton murderers row keith robinson
everybody trash me
uh i was i was basically debating
whether or not i was going to do this
gig
it was the gig was basically i think i
told this before but just for new
listeners i'll go through it real quick
uh the yankees were playing the atlanta
braves
in the [ __ ] world series i'd never
been to a world series game
and uh so they called up the comedy
seller and they wanted two comedians
um they wanted two comedians to do
do this [ __ ] gig which was basically
they had rented two buses and they were
gonna drive up to the stadium they
wanted a comedian to do stand-up
on the bus and uh they offered it to me
and jim norton
and me and jim sat there going you're
gonna do it i'm like i don't know you're
gonna do it i don't know it's gonna be
rough but both wanted to go to the game
it's unbeknownst to me he told este he
wasn't gonna [ __ ] do it and i was
still hemming and hauling about it and i
made fun of his shirt and he said
whatever busboy
and the whole [ __ ] table stopped and
everybody was like what
and he goes billboard's doing a [ __ ]
gig on a bus
to get a world series ticket and there
just wasn't enough time for me trying to
explain well i'm just contemplating it
they offered it to him it was over
and i took a [ __ ] about a 50 minute
pounding
50 minutes straight like a headlining
set of just getting
trashed and um
so anyway so they sent this [ __ ] uh
and you know what i actually i didn't
end up doing the gig but still i don't i
don't think the gig was that bad
a gig that would have been such an easy
[ __ ] gig you just get on the bus
and you just trash the yankees and when
you run out of [ __ ] you make fun of
somebody
hey look at that tits on her that's all
you have to do
you make fun of yourself this has got to
be
the great you know a lot of you are
probably thinking this is a horrible
this is one of the greatest
just make fun of that this is actually a
good gig in your career
you could be drinking with them having
chance
[ __ ] the eggs [ __ ] the you know just get
them genuinely yell at other people on
the side you can just
anything to distract you just filibuster
for a [ __ ] 20 minute ride up there
and you go to world series game for free
i stand by it i stand by i still don't
think it was a bad gig
although the person who did the gig but
he was less experienced than me who
actually
maybe i'll him on the podcast someday he
actually has his own tv show right now
see that and i don't so there was magic
on that bus
he actually did it and i finally i told
him i took the pounding
and uh you know took it like a champ
just sat there and took it [ __ ]
killed killed me for 50 [ __ ] minutes
and i never gave up his name i was like
that guy in casino getting his eye
popped out
i didn't even bring it up that i
actually i could have just said i'm not
doing the gig i gave it to somebody else
or maybe i hadn't given it to him at
that point had i
i can't remember i just remember in the
end i was still going to do it until
it finally had died down and patrice
just said to me bill
he goes i will stand in front of that
bus
you can't do that gig all right you want
to go to the world series buy a ticket
and i was just like wow i guess i should
have some sort of [ __ ] self-esteem
smash cut the [ __ ] eight years later
ten whatever how many years it is i'm
being offered a wedding gig
um yeah i'm gonna say no i'm just
because
even even if uh you know i needed to
fill the calendar
it's just like it's your wedding day you
want it you want it to be nice you don't
want somebody going i mean you just saw
my act you saw what i talked about i'm
talking about the [ __ ]
apocalypse and people eating puppies i
mean you really want me to i don't have
like a wedding set if that's what you're
asking me
i i really wouldn't know uh i really
wouldn't know what to do
so uh but i'm great i'm glad that you
had a good time uh that new haven gig
was the [ __ ]
and that's something i definitely want
to do again like i said i want to come
back for the harvard yale game
go to a home game there and i just want
to listen into some of the conversations
and who knows i'll probably be sitting
next to
uh one a future president or maybe
someone who's
in the future will be the guy who has
the on high like cloaked robe before he
stabs a virgin
at some sort of bilderberg cookout um
all right
apocalypse hello billiam i am a
dedicated podcast listener i'm a big fan
of
i've noticed your recent musings on
preparing for the apocalypse
buying guns i haven't done any of it i
just think about doing it and then nia
just looks at me and just shakes her
head like you're out of your [ __ ]
mind
uh buying guns learning how to hunt and
survive when the inevitable human
population bubble bursts and we run out
of food and water
uh well i don't think that's going to
happen anytime soon it eventually will
happen and it may very well happen
within my lifetime
okay well i guess you plan on living a
long time then sir
um because i don't think it's gonna
happen at any time soon but probably in
my lifetime
when you think you know in the overall
history of how long
man has walked the planet and woman that
that's kind of soon
we've been around how long we've been
around
100 000 years i don't [ __ ] know
we've been we haven't been around that
long have we jesus wasn't walking the
earth 2 000 years ago
he didn't have an ipad what the [ __ ] he
did
they went to kill him did they did they
use a lethal injection or electric chair
they
tied him to a [ __ ] stake
if you believe in that stuff you know
i'm not trying to offend anybody some
people don't believe it even happened
some people only believe that the guy
even existed some people think it was
just all made up
i'm not trying to offend anybody you
know
anyways like you i grew up in a big city
with them with middle class parents
relatively sheltered and didn't learn a
lot of the basic survival skills as a
kid
as an adult with children i think it's
vital
capitals vital that they learn basic
fundamental skills of survival
building a fire making shelter hunting
etc
i picked up hunting as an adult and i
have to say it has changed my
understanding of the
of the natural world man's role as a
predator on the planet
how we evolved where we fit in etc
um i cannot underscore the appreciation
you will have if you actually get out
there
harvest your own food you have to use
the word harvest when you're killing a
living thing
that's really creepy to me just say
[ __ ] blow the brains out of a [ __ ]
elk
um prepare it and then feed yourself and
your loved ones it's an experience
someone who sees the world as you do
will surely appreciate
yeah i think that's awesome but what am
i going to do am i going to go shoot a
[ __ ] deer
and then tie it to the front of my prius
and drive back down to la do you
understand what will happen to me
how [ __ ] liberal it is out here
i'll get [ __ ] stabbed to death with
horseshoes on hollywood boulevard
um if you want to get really back to
basics you should learn to hunt without
a gun
i actually think that's cool hunting
without a gun is great
he said bullets make life easy i i keep
the bullets for uh for people
um he said bullets make life easy but
when the [ __ ] really hits the fed you're
gonna need to save those bullets and all
likelihood to protect yourself from yeah
from other people actually already read
that so maybe his id was already my head
uh don't kid yourself the most dangerous
animal on the planet is a hungry human
who wants what you have
forget about lions bears etc they don't
compare yeah that's goddamn right
i don't live next to a lion but i live
next to a bunch of human beings
um learn to hunt with the bow and arrow
the arrows are recoverable and reusable
if you want to get really fancy have
someone take you out to hunt with dogs
or birds of prey
or both dude i gotta say birds of prey
freak me out
they really freak me out they just uh
they don't look um
they're not domesticated i don't like
how you gotta put like that [ __ ] uh
special needs helmet over their [ __ ]
heads yeah or else they'll i don't know
what they'll do
and i don't like those talons it's like
they got a butterfly knife
attached to both foot they're like
freddy krueger and just one day i don't
know what's going to happen you know
they
confuse my face with some sort of
red-chested robin or something i don't
know
claw out my eyes um
and they always look angry like owls
always look pissed off
you know it's got that dan deardolf line
right above his nose
his beak i mean um by the way just in
case you think i'm a fringe wacko
a wackadoo i'm a board-certified
physician
and my wife went to both medical school
and law school
well that really didn't prove anything
sir you just said that by the way if you
think and if you think i'm crazy
uh i also flew the space shuttle sir um
well tell me how do i do it where do i
learn how to hunt
i want to you know what i want to kill i
want to kill a varmint i could kill a
varmint
um
could i though i'd have to be really
hungry i know i could do
it anybody could do it you just have to
be hungry enough
unless you knew about berries you know
uh wouldn't that be the worst if you're
[ __ ] out in the wilderness right and
you don't know how to survive or hunt
but you're with somebody out there who
knows how to survive and is like a
[ __ ] vegan
and you're just sitting there eating
nuts and berries and [ __ ] right
sticking your face in a beehive trying
to lick up some honey get stung in the
face like a goddamn brown bear
instead of just killing a rabbit and you
guys got to deal with this guy you know
what happened eventually eventually you
just you just
you pick up a branch pretend it was like
a walking stick and you just you'd keep
clubbing over the head
just in a moment of frustration and then
have that panic of being alone in the
wilderness not knowing how to get out
did i just pitch a short film um
you know i smoked a cigar last night and
i got like third of the way through it i
was like i'm done with this [ __ ]
habit now i got a stupid [ __ ]
what do you call those things humidor
anybody want a [ __ ] humidor you just
want one
you want to just take this [ __ ]
disgusting habit out of my life i don't
want to do it anymore
you know [ __ ] horrific it's a
horrific [ __ ] habit you know how i
know it is
because there's not a bad smell to a dog
a dog will walk up to another up dog's
fresh pile of [ __ ] and stick his nose
right in it
and can have it there it doesn't gag or
anything all right if i'm sitting there
with my cigar it won't come anywhere
near me
now what does that tell you cigars
smell worse than poodle [ __ ] okay
all right the truth behind pink uh bill
you should check out the
the outer documentary titled pink
ribbons inc
it discusses the culture and popularity
of breast cancer awareness month
while exposing some of the hypocrisy
involved in case you don't watch it let
me give you a couple of highlights
you can talk about the film without
actually having seen it well thank you
sir you got right down to the core of
who i am
give me the cliff notes what do we got
here what do we got here
um the woman that invented the pink
rhythm as a method to raise awareness
quickly one of the most annoying phrases
out there raising awareness
could it be any more [ __ ] vague
they achieve it i'm aware it's breast
cancer awareness month i got it
everyone's in the nfl is wearing pink
i am aware job done now nobody can [ __ ]
with all the money that you took in
is that the loophole that's what i'm
trying to guess then you go out and you
you buy a a pink bentley but they can't
get you because it's pink
right i'm raising awareness
okay and i spent this amount of money on
this car to show how serious the problem
is
raise awareness for breast cancer uh uh
was approached by
self sorry the woman then invented the
uh
the the [ __ ] was uh approached by the
magazine self
a magazine aimed at the ladies
how do you say that este estee lauder
that's one of those things i've heard
people say a zillion times i just
i don't know uh in the early 90s uh to
partner with these corporations knowing
that these greedy [ __ ] were only
interested in the pink rhythm as a way
to increase their bottom line the
creator of the original pink ribbon
refused to correct collaborate and told
self and esther lauder
estee lauder uh to go [ __ ] themselves so
these corporate [ __ ] created a pink
ribbon
that was technically a different color
and the pink
saturation began another interesting
point the film makes
is that companies like why did you have
to pick estee lauder
i just said it right estee lauder there
it is promote breast cancer awareness by
turning
pink the labels of products that contain
carcinogens
isn't that [ __ ] hilarious uh of the
money that buying all this pink
[ __ ] raises apparently only 15 of it is
used for researching
prevention of breast cancer most of the
research goes to figuring out which
cancer drugs work
best for treating the disease once it
occurs yeah and nothing preventative
because the money is not in the cure
it's in the treatment
anyway check out the movie pink ribbon
inc it's available on netflix instant
thanks for the podcast and all the free
funny well you're welcome sir um
yeah yeah i mean i'm at that
read that book that i'm reading uh i
mean take it for whatever you want i
mean obviously i'm not a nutritionist
but the uh
that eat to live book where it talks
about vegetables and that type of thing
and uh
and fruits and all the uh antioxidants
and how it
i know helps regenerate some damaged
cells from all the [ __ ] that you do
i really believe it just once a day if
you just have a giant [ __ ] salad
and eat a couple pieces of fruit you can
offset all that other stuff because i
gotta tell you there's no way
i'm ever gonna a hundred percent uh just
never have a steak again
you know what i mean sorry there's just
some steer out there that's gonna have
to [ __ ] die
by the way why do they have that in the
commercial why do they have a cow saying
eat more chicken
they don't feed your cows it steers and
a steer is basically a bowl with its
balls locked off as far as i can tell
that's what i was told
back in the day when i would do college
gigs and
uh i would see bull i'd randomly see a
bull
and i would see a bunch of cows and then
i would see steer and i'd be like all
right a bull's a male
a cow's a female what the [ __ ] is a
steer and they said it was a bull with
the balls lopped off
so i when they like eunuchs they don't
hit puberty
i don't [ __ ] know anyways um
next question here on the podcast uh
gyno
gyno hey bill what's your opinion on
this my wife recently
had a a gyno a porn i hate that just
gynecologist
gyno makes it sound like it's all goopy
and gross
that's disgusting but that's what i
think
a gynecological appointment as
a thoughtful husband i remembered so
later in the day i casually asked my
wife hey how'd the appointment go
she said the doctor said everything
looks great i was incredulous
i don't know what that means but i think
it means you're upset he said i said
what
what did he say she said he said
everything looks great
i said no no no no wait wait wait really
really what what what were his
his exact words she said those were his
exact words
everything looks great then he writes
[ __ ] are you kidding me bill
does that comment seem completely
unprofessional you
i mean he's a freaking doctor he should
have said something like everything
looks in order or everything looks
healthy
these goddamn doctors remember that dr
mancini from melrose place he was a real
sob they're all like that especially
these creepy gynos
what kind of guy becomes a gyno stop
saying that word sir
what the [ __ ] is this what the [ __ ] just
popped up on my goddamn computer in the
middle of a critical moment get the [ __ ]
out of here
um anyways get back plus my wife is very
attractive and now he's telling her that
her [ __ ] looks great
[Laughter]
the guy says hey i know her [ __ ] looks
great that's part of why i
married her we're really [ __ ] me
though is that i had to pay this guy
50 a 50 copay for his observation
it's like he's laughing at me anyway
what do you think about all that
i wouldn't mind nia's opinion as well
uh should i get involved here
thanks don't mention my name all right
all right um
you know what you what you should do is
just
do what you just did to me because what
you're saying is funny
you just say it to your wife in a funny
way
and just be and just be like what who
what does this guy look like does he
look like this dr mancini from melrose
place i don't know what he looks like
but that guy sounds like a
[ __ ] sleaze bag you know
why does he get to just look at you you
know i had to buy you a ring i had a
wine and dinya to do all this type of
stuff i actually love you
and i only see it a couple of times a
month you get on there for
just something there's got to be
something funny that because there is
something actually
uh um i don't know women might not agree
with this but there's something
caring about this you know
i see how much you know you're into your
wife you know like some other guy just
looking at it
without saying something uh well you
know ah [ __ ] my [ __ ] phone
who is this who is this and what do you
want i'm in the middle of talking about
gyno um
yeah i think you know if your wife's a
hot [ __ ] she'll get a kick out of it
like that's the kind of thing that would
make uh
that would make me a laugh if i ever
said something like that
oh yeah how long was he checking you out
did he have you lay on your belly
[Laughter]
yeah i got to check the other side of
the uh the uh your vagina just uh
on your belly just laying your belly and
sort of uh just point your your your
buttocks they'd use like those those
words so it didn't sound perverted
you know with the ceiling um oh speaking
of perverted
i can't even get into this
let's just say earlier in the podcast
i mentioned that i went to something and
saw some people that i hadn't seen in a
long time and uh
let's just say uh some older creep from
the faculty
showed up for whatever [ __ ] reason
you know there's always one
there's always one um
creepy okay overrated underrated um
underrated uh going to your high school
reunion
and uh overrated getting [ __ ] blitzed
at your high school if you i think if
you're like if you're five-year your
10-year you can go in there and get a
little bit [ __ ] you definitely get
drunk
at your five year 25 year you know get a
nice little buzz going
plus uh you know i don't know if you
like the kids you went to school with
you want to be able to remember what the
[ __ ] you said you know
anyways underrated having a tight ass
for a boss
as much as everyone wishes that their
boss wasn't such an [ __ ]
it's about 20 times worse to have a cool
boss that cuts corner
cuts corners and doesn't do their part
yeah then the company goes under and
then you're looking for work
um overrated bill whenever you see a
list of the greatest movies ever made
you will always see
gone with the wind on that list right my
family and i decided to watch it for the
first time on thanksgiving it was
[ __ ]
horrible it's basically a three-hour
movie about a self-centered [ __ ]
throughout the movie you watch this
[ __ ] gold dig her way through
without any remorse for anyone else
besides the protagonist being unlikely
unlikable
the plot is [ __ ] stupid i it really
has no point when the movie ended i
yelled that's
it that's the big [ __ ] ending avoid
at all costs
none of us liked it uh
i got it i have to watch it now isn't
that the one where he ends franklin my
dear
i don't give a damn that was basically
the 1940s version of saying yeah why
don't you go [ __ ] yourself you [ __ ]
all right you're going to be old and
your tits are going to fall and then
where you're going to be
huh your hair teased up on all those
goddamn noodles sitting here on the
[ __ ] plantation
what are you gonna do then not even the
non-hired help will listen to you
so go [ __ ] yourself right there soon to
be flabby tits
okay if you're not coming with love all
you gots is your looks
okay there's no botox at this point in
in in history
you're finished all right so why don't
you get over here
and suck this dick while you still can
and then learn and they roll the [ __ ]
credits
all right neolog preview here everybody
um
this was sent to me hey bill love the
podcast back cataloging it like crazy
thank you here's my [ __ ] problem
i got a roommate who is wonderful where
buddies
we watch stupid you know what [ __ ] this
i gotta make this i gotta make this
larger this print is too small
here we go i've actually learned how to
do this select everything
uh go up here go from 12.
let's make it [ __ ] 18 like a
grandmother there we go
all right i got a roommate who's
wonderful
we're buddies we watch stupid [ __ ] and
laugh together
about it all right uh he's got this
girlfriend who's
a drain on everything that is fun in the
world i'm not talking about the regular
guy girl argument crap i mean everything
quick example we were watching that bbc
planet earth series
and we're just joking at the most
beautiful [ __ ] in the world
literally and all she could do is [ __ ]
about how ugly
the birds were complaining about david
attenborough's voice or get mad at some
animal just because it's killing another
animal to [ __ ] survive
after we finished she said she would
love to be on the crew
of a nature documentary shoot she's got
no soul
the guy loves her they've been together
for over a year but it's so clear he
can't stand to be around her they only
ever argue
oh they only argue and not in that great
way that you and nia did in one of the
podcasts
where you all laughed with each other
it's unbearable and she's at my
apartment
five days a week yeah dude you know
something i get it you're in a
relationship but either move in with
this [ __ ] or let's have a [ __ ]
two days here two days there you know
you got eight home games a year you got
eight away games in the nfl
let's try to set it up the same [ __ ]
way so this is like baseball
at some point you gotta have a [ __ ]
road trip okay there's sport
um anyways most nights i eventually
either drink or smoke
or just so i'm not in the same world
as her and i like smoking who am i
kidding
uh i want to talk to him about it but
he's a really private guy we've never
talked about his relationship stuff he
stands to
he tends to steer away from it it's
becoming pretty obvious that i can't
stand this girl
nor can any of our friends i'm afraid
that she's going to drive us apart
then feast on his soul so she can try
and find some kind of personality for
herself
how do you think i should approach this
with this guy i got a right to complain
to him
about this girl right got to do it
tenderly or something
um all right this is the deal
i almost started singing when a man
loves a woman but i'm not gonna do that
to you
but it's true okay
when a man loves a woman that's no other
way to get into this point
i can't believe i was able to say that
without singing it
even even i as bad as i sing no i can't
even
you want me to do it all right
um there's no [ __ ] way
you can approach um
the [ __ ] things that annoy you about
them
what you have to do is just walk into
another room and just like
literally just grab a pillow off of the
couch
you know after she says something you
just walk in the other room you just go
and then you just come back in and you
go oh so what are you majoring in right
you just do that but
you do have a right as a roommate to
have some sort of parameters
all right the problem is is you've let
it get out of control
all right so here's the deal
either this dude's gonna marry this girl
or he isn't
okay he's gonna marry this girl your
guys
your friendship is [ __ ] over you're
not gonna hang out with him because he's
he's with this colossal [ __ ]
you're gonna meet somebody else then
eventually you're gonna get married
you're gonna have kids you're barely
gonna have time to see this person
anyways even if you liked his wife
okay but the fact that she's a [ __ ]
she's just gonna fade out anyways
okay so there's nothing to worry about
there
losing this friendship if he's gonna
marry this girl it's [ __ ] over dude
okay it's a done deal all right um
and if he's eventually gonna break up
with her whatever you're going to say to
him now he's eventually going to come
around
and he's going to be saying all the [ __ ]
that you're going to say to him or want
to say to him so you don't need to say
it
you just get you all what you really
have to deal with right now is just
trying to cut down the amount of time
that that
[ __ ] that that that hell [ __ ]
comes into your apartment five days a
week dude i don't care if you even like
to just say listen
um i respect you and your relationship
you know i'm really happy for you you
seem really happy
but you know it's just uh
this is [ __ ] hard she's coming over
here five days a week
can is there any way you can you can
kind of cut that in half coupled nights
over her place because i like to come
out here i like to smoke a [ __ ] bong
and i like to watch the [ __ ] tv well
you can do that you can do that with
cheat hair
oh boy yeah but she i
like to do it in a a a country
atmosphere
there's no [ __ ] way to do this um
you know what you're just basically
gonna have to ask yourself what's more
important to you
your friendship with this guy or your
your [ __ ]
uh you know
your ability to [ __ ] have a beer and
smoke a joint without this [ __ ] [ __ ]
ruining you
you know five nights a week okay i would
suggest this okay if you still want to
be friends with this guy you don't want
to rock the boat then i would look for
another place to live
if you could which [ __ ] sucks you got
to pay to move but i'm telling you
you're going to be psyched
how old are you dude maybe it's time you
should [ __ ] live alone
you know because you might jump out of
this out of the fire and out of the
fire into the what and out of the frying
pan into the fire
dude this is [ __ ] rough
i don't know how to just say listen dude
i don't know how to say this to you
because i feel like however i say it
you're going to feel like i'm attacking
you
and that you know you're going to say
something to your girlfriend and she's
going to think that i don't like her
which i don't um just say listen she's
coming over here five days a week
she's not paying rent you know i like
hanging out watching tv you know i'm
coming over here she's taking up half
the couch
i just need just can we cut it down to
four days a week three days a week
i don't mind her coming over here just
not five out of the seven days
all right i want to come out of my
underwear rub my balls drink a [ __ ]
beer and watch the game
i don't want to come out here you know
dress like uh i'm
on father's nose best you know you know
back in the day the fathers would walk
around the house in a goddamn suit
right
you know what dude sometimes you just
gotta burn a friendship
there's all different ways you can do
that you could just you could just be
honest and just say listen dude if
this [ __ ] girl comes over here one
more time
so do you like want me to cut it down to
like three days a week no how about zero
how about you break up with her and
realize you can get somebody better how
about that
you know i don't know so that that is
definitely a rough one i
i i gave you a number of options
um i would in no way
say how you feel about that girl dear
buddy you can't do that
um i mean you can't but there's just
going to be ramifications to that but uh
i would definitely try to get that
you know try to get that number knocked
down
all right did i just say the same thing
for [ __ ] 20 minutes over and over
again all right there's an hour there's
an hour for you
all right that's the monday morning
podcast for this week uh i'm going to be
at the
brea comedy club in uh
in brea california let me get to my
[ __ ] website that evidently that
guy's got me feeling bad about
you give a [ __ ] about your fans i hope
you do
because if you don't it's really sad
oh jesus shows here we go i'm going to
be at the brea improv
uh november 30th december 1st
and december 2nd all right
friday saturday sunday of this week this
is my last headlining gig
of the year if your dream
was to see me at some point in 2012 this
is your last chance
um i guarantee you're gonna see a great
show because i'm loving my act right now
and um i took last weekend off and i'm
jumping at the bit to get on stage i got
a bunch of new
[ __ ] up [ __ ] that i want to talk about
and uh i watched something the other
night that i got really inspired by i
actually watched the documentary of the
making of
michael jackson's bad and it just made
me feel like i
i don't work nearly you know i don't
work hard enough
was really [ __ ] inspiring and also
killed me as i got off at that subway
stop where they uh where they
shot the the whole dance thing for bad
and it's weird it's like you come down
the stairs and there's a middle level
then you go downstairs again
and the amount of times i ran through
there
trying to [ __ ] catch a train and
didn't even look around
i wonder if i looked around i would have
noticed it i think would have to be like
nobody in there if it was a bunch of
people i don't think i would have
noticed but if i was there
late at night and i was looking around
making sure i wasn't going to get jumped
you know i wonder if i would have
noticed
i probably wouldn't have i probably
won't even notice if i was [ __ ]
coming down
with my ipod listening to the song bet
[Music]
walk right by um anyways all right
that's the podcast for this week
uh thank you everybody for listening i
hope you had a great thanksgiving
um and that is it and um
thanks to the person who organized the
high school union like i said i don't
name names here
uh i had a great time and i think i'm
gonna go to the next one
all righty that's it go [ __ ] yourselves
i'll talk to you next week oh geez
you